La volta al món a peu, dia 295. Avui és diumenge, dia 20 de setembre, segueixo Caixgar i en aquest bloc explicaré i us ensenyaré coses ràndoms que fem aquests dies visitant la ciutat i els voltants.
Ara, anem a la que és la principal atracció, com a mínim això ens va dir el Harry, que és el mercat de bestiar de Caixgar, que es veu que és brutal.
En comptes d'agafar un taxi com persones civilitzades, volen agafar una escúter elèctrica d'aquestes que es pot llogar i pagar amb l'AliPay.
Jo no sé conduir moto, però això deu ser fàcil.
A la meva moto el casc va així amb aquest cable i crec que m'ha atès algú. És bastant simple, però jo no sé anar amb la moto.
Bé, tinc assegurances d'escriure, assegurances que em cobreix de tot.
Espero que també em cobreixi.
I assegurances a tercers, perquè hi ha moltíssimes motos, moltíssima gent i crec que m'ha atès algú.
Amb aquest codi d'escompte teniu assegurances que us escriu per quan aneu de viatge a la Xina o on sigui.
No m'ha atès ningú, però ha sigut un fail total perquè resulta que el mercat aquest està a les afores de la ciutat
i has de fer una petita part del trajecte interurbà i la moto té com un GPS i quan detecta que estàs fora de la zona urbana es para.
I no hem pogut continuar i hem hagut de tornar enrere i no la pots aparcar a qualsevol lloc, l'has d'aparcar a un lloc específic,
cosa que em sembla bastant bé, però en fi, un fail. O sigui, haguéssim anat molt millor amb taxi, però en fi, he sobreviscut.
Hi ha moltíssima gent. El mercat està dividit en dos. La part dels animals que està allà, els animals vius, i aquí és la part del menjar, que és on estan els animals d'allà, venen aquí morts.
I bé, primer hem vingut a menjar perquè estàvem morts de gana i bé, uns fideus així freds una mica reguleros, però després unes brotxetes amb carn de porc, diria.
I bé, unes brotxetes amb carn de porc, diria.
Hi ha mòrgoles, tu! Mòrgoles! Em fa vergonya preguntar quant costen. A Catalunya costa una fortuna, no? Diuen que és el bolet més apreciat. No ho sé, no l'he provat mai la mòrgola, eh?
Però sí, sí, sí. Sí, sí, molt bé. Bueno, va, anem a veure els animals.
Aquesta és la zona de les vaques. Crec que va per subhasta, perquè veig la gent que va fent...
Com dient... Tranquil, nano.
És una locura, això. És una locura.
El que és un tema és que hagués hagut de venir amb les gammes antigues perquè me n'he comprat unes de noves.
Mira, dintre vídeo.
Bona tarda, estic aquí amb els bros d'ahir.
I... Bueno, en Harry ens ha portat a dinar a un lloc de noodles.
Mare meva, el tamany del bol de noodles.
Però, flipes.
Flipes.
Jo no ho havia dit.
I és mai algú tan gran.
M'ha costat 3 euros.
Brutal, està molt bo.
I li he dit, escolta, crec que m'hauria d'anar a mirar unes sabates.
O sigui, unes sabatilles per comprar.
I en Harry em diu, ah, vine, vine.
És que porta molt de temps aquí, el Harry.
I s'ho coneix tot. Ara estem fora del centre històric, com podeu veure.
I els edificis són brutals.
Li he dit, com pot ser que una ciutat de només 250.000 habitants tingui tot això?
I diu, no, no, és que no té 250.000.
Té un milió.
Ho hem mirat i sí, sí, la Wikipedia en català està equivocada o desactualitzada.
Però sí, sí, gairebé un milió de tota la zona urbana.
I mira, tots aquests centres comercials flipants, tot enorme.
I es veu que hi ha una...
Aquí, això, un centre comercial on tenen un munt de botigues d'esports.
I, bueno, miraré. A veure si hi ha el meu número.
No ho crec, però ho veurem.
Parla una mica de xinès i tot.
A la Xina, evidentment, les talles van diferent i va depenent del tamany del teu peu, literalment.
Si el teu peu medeix 30 centímetres, doncs tens aquesta talla.
Preguntant-li a l'EIA es veu que el meu peu medeix 29,5 centímetres.
I tenen, la tenen, sembla. Vaig a provar.
També et diré que aquesta no seria la meva preferida perquè, com veieu,
sí que té una mica de taco, però no, és un taco de trail running i és superblanca.
Vull dir que això és un taco de trail running.
Això es petarà de seguida, però, bueno, com a mínim, per saber la talla, vaig a provar-les.
No m'anava malament de talla, però eren massa, massa, massa, com ho diria?
Massa, que s'haguessin fet malbé de seguida i no eren per fer molts quilòmetres i tal.
He demanat unes altres que m'han agradat, a veure si tenen el meu...
No!
Ah, mira, n'hi ha unes que m'han... Mira, aquestes tenen el meu número.
Doncs molaven bastant aquestes i les tenien, però, sort que m'ha vingut per preguntar,
eren waterproof.
Però tenien Gore-Tex i no, perquè se'n feia el peu amb el Gore-Tex.
Bueno, no perdem l'esperança, hi ha moltes més botigues. A veure si trobo, a veure si trobo.
Unes altres que m'agraden i em van bé, el número, però també són waterproof, tu.
Aquestes m'agraden, eh? Una d'aquestes, jo ara en porto unes altres.
Doncs bé, al final he comprat unes marca Peak.
No són les perfectes, no, però són de les poques que tenien la meva talla
i, a veure si tenen el meu número.
I, a veure si tenen el meu número.
De les que m'he provat, tenen les més còmodes, en diferència.
A veure, tampoc són molt guapes, però, bueno, estan bé així negres.
La sola, com podeu veure, no és de trail, no és de muntanya.
És d'asfalt, però, bueno, sincerament, crec que a partir d'ara no faré molta muntanya.
El que ve, la següent part que ve fins a Índia, aquestes sabates m'han de portar fins a la Índia.
Pakistan, jo crec que camins de terra, trialeres, com a molt,
però allò, terrenys tècnics, no crec que faci perquè, clar, és que ja no és època perquè ja començarà a fer fred.
I encara que hagi de fer alguna cosa tècnica, sincerament, a veure, jo crec que això va bé.
Són bastant amortiguades, però no tant com unes altres que m'he provat,
que literalment anaves com una molla, saps?
I el problema és que posa que són water resistant.
Clar, això no vol dir waterproof, és com mig-mig, no?
És com que la tela és una mica impermeable.
Impermeable, però no del tot.
Ja saps que a mi les sabates impermeables no m'agraden gens.
Sincerament, no són les meves preferides, no crec que siguin les que millor transpirin,
més tracció tinguin, no, què va, però és el que hi ha, tu, és el que hi ha.
I no m'arrisco a portar l'escuca aquesta fins a l'Islamabad, que potser no m'aguanten.
Així que, mira, aquestes són les que m'han de portar fins a l'Índia.
A veure què tal.
A part de les gambes, ha estat una estona aquí, a la zona de fumadors,
en passant fum d'altra gent, perquè estava a gravar una entrevista amb Esplugues FM.
Jo soc d'Esplugues, i ara és la festa major d'Esplugues,
llavors crec que si aneu a la web trobareu l'entrevista,
que me l'ha fet, en part, el meu pare, que està a Esplugues FM.
I el podcast. Molts em preguntaven el podcast, Enric, quan torna el podcast?
Doncs ja ha tornat.
Ara vam gravar un capítol fa uns dies, suposo que aquesta setmana tornarem a gravar.
Bueno, aneu mirant l'Instagram, que ho vaig anunciant,
i si no, ho busqueu a Spotify, al món als teus peus.
Torna el podcast amb el Sergi Marí.
Llavors, clar, doncs, les he portat aquí, i ha estat omplida de merda, el terra.
Ja veuràs com me les emmortaré.
Hi ha algunes absolutament enormes.
També venen, pel que he vist, bous, toros, perquè...
Uau, mira aquestes, mira aquestes vaques, tio.
Jo mai he vist una vaca tan gran, eh?
Ni a Suïssa.
Bogeria de lloc.
Ha, ha, ha.
Aquesta és la zona de les ovelletes.
Les blanques o les negres?
Són negres, la majoria.
Però tenen uns canons especials, algunes, eh?
Unes banyes d'aquestes, així...
Sóc molt pixapí, eh? No tinc ni idea de races de vaca, d'ovella, ni de res.
Ostres, mira aquelles, que mones, tu.
Look at those ones, so cute.
Vídeo no apte per animalistes, ni per vegetarians, ni per vegans, eh?
Fa una mica de pena, eh?, de dir-vos tot això.
De peu ens ho mengem, vull dir, és el que hi ha, saps?, però...
Fa una mica de peneta.
El 90% del mercat són vaques i ovelles, que suposo que és el que la gent menja.
Aquí hi ha els cavalls, i ens han dit que també els camells.
Que és el que jo tinc ganes de veure.
Però no en veig cap, eh? De moment només veig cavalls, ponis...
Aquí està el camell.
Només n'hi ha un en tot el mercat.
Ha, ha, ha.
Suposo que és un animal una mica inútil, no?
Però és que molt agatxat, eh?
És una espècie de camells que només es troben aquí, crec, a aquesta zona del Pamir.
La diferència entre un dromedari i un camell és que el camell té dues llepes i el dromedari una.
Molt bé, doncs ja ho hem vist.
Bueno, última activitat del dia d'avui, venim a un casament.
És una cosa que des del primer dia que he estat aquí m'han dit que podies venir,
i a mi em sembla molt raro, però bueno, ho intentaré.
O sigui, jo venir a un casament amb aquesta roba, i a més un casament que no és el meu,
no sé, em sembla com raro, em sembla decoplat.
Però bueno, es veu que és una experiència genial.
Hem vingut una estona abans, perquè comença a les vuit i són les set i pico per agafar lloc,
i és aquí, és a un hotel.
I bueno, es veu que és època de casaments i cada dia n'hi ha un.
Bueno, no sé, ara us ensenyo el que hi ha.
Es veu que els convidats, evidentment, estan aquí a baix, sentats a les taules,
i els espectadors estem a dalt mirant.
Molt raro.
Hi ha una banda que està com assajant, calentant els instruments.
Això promet.
Encara són les vuit i ja hi ha un fonambulista.
Uau.
Passaran moltes coses que no entendrem.
Aquest és un dels instruments que us he dit que és com molt típic,
la guitarra aquesta que sona una mica estranya.
El tambor aquest.
I la trompeta, que sona com un sac de jamecs.
Sí, l'hem d'estrenar.
La guitarra elèctrica.
No ho sé doncs.
O de noies.
La noia.
No, sí, la noia.
No ho sé, veus.
No ho sé.
Allá, allá, allá.
Ay, allá, allá.
Calla, allá, allá.
Calla, allá.
Ay, allá, allá.
Calla, allá, allá.
Calla, allá.
Gi mita imbatua.
Gitara elèctrica?
Què dius?
Com ho crec?
No entenc res.
La guitarra elèctrica ara.
Heavy metal.
Increïble la quantitat de gent a les grades, mira, mira, ara baixa la núvia amb un vel, no se la veu gaire, molt divertit això.
A la núvia se la du clarament, ara li han pres una espècie de cosa vermella per sobre, però el nòvio no sé si encara ha d'arribar o és aquest home que està just a sota que li acaben de posar una bufanda negra.
No sé si ho he dit abans, però és una boda uigur, ja es veu pels instruments i pels barrets que porten.
El nòvio amb el cap molt baixat, eh? No, no pot ser aquest el nòvio, no pot ser. Deu ser el germà.
Viva la núvia!
Ah, doncs sí que era el nòvio, eh? Sí, aquí tenim la taula presidencial.
Jo no entenc per què tapant anar la núvia, si no podrà menjar, així.
Bueno, tu, això durarà fins a les 12 i jo crec que d'aquí una o dues hores o tres començaran a ballar, llavors serà divertit, però no ens quedem tanta estona, home.
Quedar-se dues o tres hores aquí de peu esperant que ballin i veure mentre es mengen, doncs, fa una mica d'atractiu aquest pla, no?
Mira, torna a passar el son embolista. El que farem serà anar a veure música en directe xinesa a les muralles de Kashgar.
Ja és la segona nit que vinc aquí, m'encanta, és la muralla aquesta segur que està reconstruïda, i tot són baretos i concerts amb la música una mica forta,
he de dir. Música rock xinesa, és bastant curiós. I, doncs, diries, ui, és tan guai aquí al costat de la torre aquesta, la Nòria, seria molt car?
I no, la veritat és que no. Encara ens fan menjar la graella i tal. Molt xulo, molt xulo. Bueno, demà, dia clau per les postals, a veure si les consegueixo enviar.
Dimarts 22 de setembre, a les 11 del matí, encara no ha arribat la visa de Pakistan, he intentat trucar a l'embarassador, però no ha arribat.
Vaig deixar a Dushanbe, ni l'agafen, crec que ni funciona trucar, bueno, he de trucar a una aplicació especial perquè aquí no tinc número per trucar.
Bueno, fent, avui fa unes distàncies més. Però, tema postals, avui ha de ser el dia clau, avui ha de ser, oh mira, està tancat el supermercat, aquí venien cafè.
Bueno, avui és el dia clau, les postals ja estan a correus, però he de portar els diners, perquè, bueno, sempre passa el mateix a correus, diuen que el sistema no funciona i que he de pagar en efectiu.
Bueno.
Total, que, bueno, ara vaig a un caixer automàtic a trobar diners i després a correus.
Que, a més, els he de fer un favor, he de trucar a un client espanyol que es veu que el seu paquet ha sigut retornat perquè portava una bateria.
I per fer-los aquest favor ahir m'han regalat un pa. A veure què tal.
Fet. Ha costat bastant. És de les vegades que ha costat més tota la logística i tot plegat d'enviar les postals.
Aquesta vegada hi ha molta gent que s'havia donat d'alta els últims dies i sempre que hi ha gent que dona d'alta molta gent no em dona la seva adreça perquè no s'entera de com va o el que sigui.
I, bueno, jo els he enviat missatges, tal, he perseguit, però tampoc puc estar perseguint constantment la gent.
Llavors, mira, a la gent que no m'ha enviat la seva adreça fins ara, em sap greu, però no puc tornar una sisena vegada a l'oficina de correus. Em sap greu. Ja la d'octubre.
El tema de l'espanyol, el tema de la bateria, no era espanyol. Em diuen australià. No, apunto el número i el prefix era d'Austràlia.
Volien que truqués amb el meu número de telèfon. A l'igual.
M'he sortit pel nuvi de la cara.
Llavors, li he enviat un whatsapp, bueno, diversos whatsapps explicant el que hi havia.
Clar, però si el tio ja està a Àustria, això és... són les sis del matí allà, per tant...
Bueno, li he enviat un missatge i...
Res, no sé què era el que tenia a dintre, que portava una bateria, i ha de tornar a pagar i l'hi enviaran sense la bateria.
No ho sé, potser està viatjant encara.
Jonathan, es deia.
Bueno, doncs aquí s'acaba el blog d'avui. No sé molt bé com haurà quedat.
Ara aniré a aquest cafè d'avui.
I l'editaré.
I avui, ho veureu això dimarts, dijous, si no hi ha cap contratemps o el que sigui,
m'agradaria fer un directe.
I el directe és complicat perquè, clar, aquí són sis hores menys, no?
Llavors intentaré que el directe sigui a les cinc de la tarda.
És el màxim tard que ho puc fer.
Per mi serà a les onze de la nit.
Durarà unes dues hores, fins a les set de la tarda.
I...
I llavors, doncs per mi serà a la una de la matinada.
Per tant...
Ja està.
Ja sé que és una mica massa d'hora, un dijous a les cinc.
Hi ha molta gent que està treballant, suposo.
Però bueno, tu...
Jo què sé.
No sé quan vindrà el visit de Pakistan. Quan arribi, doncs ja us avisaré.
De mentres, potser vaig a fer...
One second.
De mentres, potser fent algun blog de les coses que vagi fent aquí.
Jo què sé, tampoc hi ha tant a ensenyar, saps?
Està guai, però jo què sé.
Vinga, fins la propera.